hello everyone
so my name is ian oswald and i'm going
to be talking on
skinny pandas riding on a rocket
aimed at making your data science
workflows go faster
so today's goal well many of you will be
working on pandas so
we're going to look at getting more into
ram so that we can have more data in
pandas before using other tools
figuring out why some of this is slow
and figuring out ways to make it go
faster
when we need to go beyond pandas then
we'll look at a couple of new tools so
desk which will let us work on larger
data sets
and work in a multi-core scenario we'll
look briefly at
sqlite which i think is an under
recognized and underutilized
tool for sql collaboration uh which
enables uh very large files
and then we'll finish off by looking at
vagues a new competitor
against uh pandas and desk um which i
think enables uh
new workflows uh which could be really
interesting
to some of you particularly if you're
working on very large data sets
or you're a bit frustrated by pandas
being slow and you're working on one
machine
to do all of this we'll be looking at
the
uk land registry data sets that's house
purchases and house prices
it's 25 million rows
so introductions uh my name is ian
oswald i'm an interim chief they
designed
so i go into companies many of the big
brands that you'll recognize
and many smaller companies as well and
help them when
when they could do with finding out all
the mistakes that someone who's been
doing this for 20 years may have made so
that they don't have to make those same
mistakes for themselves
making new mistakes is fun repeating the
old mistakes kind of boring
so i go and help teams with strategic
planning and also going to
write intellectual properties so that
teams write to the right code and get
their products delivered
so i've been doing this for two decades
a lot of the time in
the python ecosystem and in the last
several years i've been working more on
building up
public courses particularly one around
high performance computing the first
time i presented this actually was at
euro python in 2011.
that turned into my high performance
python book co-written with misha
garlic you can see a screenshot of the
cover on the right hand side
and earlier this year we published the
second edition of that look at that it's
over 400 pages of meaty goodness about
high performance computing
all in python uh and uh some of the
material that i'll be covering in this
uh this talk today comes from my course
and
little bits from the book i'm also one
of the co-founders of the
pi data london meetup um we've got over
180 groups around the world uh you
probably know something about pi data
given that you're attending pi data
global
welcome along um i'm super proud of the
fact that pi data london is one of the
largest i think still the largest
of the meetups on the planet um
and uh you're super welcome to come and
join our community wherever you are
in the world on that note um i've been
volunteering with
pi data for over seven years we've run
an annual conference that's turned into
pi data global this year he was raising
money for the open source community i'm
sure you'll be hearing about that during
the course of the conference
remember that all of us presenting and
all of the organizers are volunteers
we're volunteering our time to make the
open source world better so as and when
you meet people online particularly the
authors whose talks you like and the
other volunteer organizers
say thank you make the world a better
place and go and say thank you
i'll give you a little caveat uh we're
dealing with some benchmarking in this
talk and of course all benchmarks are
wrong in fact benchmarks typically are
lies and they can distort the truth so i
try to make sure that none of the points
i raised here
are completely comparable um because i
think that'll be an unfair comparison
i'm not trying to set out to show that
one library is better than another i'm
just trying to show some of the
differences and strengths of some of the
libraries here
your libraries your operating system the
versions of tools that you've got and
your data
will change the results from what we see
here so of course you need to do your
own experiments don't take anything
here as being the golden truth take it
as a guide to help guide you on the
decisions you want to make
so we'll start with pandas so pandas a
little bit of background uh well pandas
uh it's a
venerable tool it's been around for a
while it grew out of numpy
i think the first release noted on the
right taken from wikipedia was around
2008 so it's 12 years old
so many design decisions have been taken
over the course of that time from when
pandas and python was much younger in
the data science game
and now over a decade later we're in a
bit of a different world
back then it made sense to load all of
the data into ram so pandas represents
everything can ramp so you have to have
enough ram
in your machine to represent it and
operations can be quite expensive
creating
temporaries and it's not unusual to
realize that uh
even with an initial data set you need
several times
the ram available to do any operations
for temporaries whilst you're
working on your data sets which means
you need quite a lot of ram even for
relatively small data sets now
it's got a very rich api it's pretty
wide as well so you can do lots of
things time series sampling text-based
analytics you can handle all sorts of
data types you can join and merge like
an sql database you can do a lot of
things in there
which means it's complicated there's
lots of time series tooling which
is important to a lot of people um it's
a well-respected project it's got a lot
of
followers on github it's got a lot of
contributions it's got a lot of issues
filed a lot of forks it's got a lot of
popularity behind it and a lot of core
contributors
let's have a brief look at some of the
data that we'll be using in here for
some of these comparisons so this is a
tiny snippet
from the uk land registry data set it's
an
open data data set 25 million rows
with lots of text columns and also
numbers and dates
uh which represents uh when house prices
uh when the sale of a house uh
uh was completed and so we get details
about it including the price the
location
um and uh the date uh and so it's a it's
a pretty good mixed uh interesting
dataset showing real world trends we'll
summarize some of those trends
um the original data set was four
gigabytes of csv that takes a good few
minutes to load into
pandas i saved out as a pickled file
that's very quick takes seconds to
export that and import it in
but even then representing this data in
memory costs 10 gigabytes even though
the file itself is 4 gigabytes
and that's because pandas isn't great at
representing string columns in
particular
in ram they get very expensive on ram so
can we do anything about that and of
course yes we can
uh we'll be using a thinner slice of
this data set
uh for some of the early slides so here
i've made df
few coals so fewer columns using the
county column that's the location
pt that's property type um d is detached
house f is flat s is semi-detached these
are property types in the uk
date is when the transaction was
completed and price is the price of the
house and look at that back in 1995
you could buy a house for 18 000 pounds
oh that's so quaint
uh now you're looking at half a million
to a million to purchase things
certainly around
the london uh and uh lots of the more
popular places in the uk
uh how inflation has changed the game
so first of all let's say uh you've
loaded a data set you're beginning to do
some operations you're discovering that
you run out of ram every now and again
or things are really slow when you're
scratching your head you're trying to
wonder
why that might be so you use the dot
info function which tells us about the
uh the size of the data set uh the
columns the data types behind the
columns
you can see on the left-hand side
dfucols.info
it says we've got 25 million items in
our
range index great so we've got 25
million rows uh we've got a account here
to your date and a price two object
columns a date time 64 and an inch 64.
well the date time 64 that's an eight
byte object and in 64 that's an eight
byte object so we know exactly how big
they are eight bytes times 25 billion
rows we can calculate the memory head
for that
the objects on the other hand we can't
trivially find out how expensive they
are in terms of ram
and so pandas reports well 777
plus megabytes it's an estimate that
plus means it's an estimate
it's an underestimate if we use dfu
calls.info
memory usage equals deep which you're
going to see on the right hand side
you'll see the true memory usage is 3.4
gigabytes
what's happening here is pandas goes
through every row for every item in that
column and says
exactly how big are you you each
individual string one at a time
counts up the individual cost it takes a
good few seconds and that gives us the
true estimate back so
what's a true measure of ram usage
rather than an underestimate
that we started with 3.4 gigabytes just
to get the data into memory before we do
anything else at all
um just for this a thin data set this is
not the wider data set that i started
with of course that was 10 gigabytes
so what can we do about that well uh
panda's introduced the
categorical data types and historically
we've had other thinner representations
of our data with
numeric columns so let's use two of
those so
i'm going to make a df slimmer coal so a
slimmer set of columns
i'm going to take my df kohl's county
and turn it into as type
category i do the same for pt and for
date
for price i'm not turning that into a
category i'm turning that into an int 32
it started out life as an into 64. so it
started with eight bytes
by going to an 32 it goes down to four
bytes for the other three
items there uh county pt and date we're
turning them into categoricals you can
access all of the same operations
underneath
so with a categorical date you can see
we've got dt uh
dropped a year for example to get out
the year but as you'll see it uses a
much less ram
so by creating this df slimmer coals and
if i do
i call it the memory usage i can see now
the memory usage is 219
megabytes so contrast that with 3.4
gigabytes that we had a moment ago
and that's because of the categorical
encoding all of the strings rather than
being repeated redundantly
many times because the count is there's
only a fixed small number of counties in
the uk
rather than repeating those redundantly
uh the unique strings are taken out and
an integer encoding is put in place
there and
the smallest integer encoding that could
be used maybe an intake when in 16 is
used
behind the scenes so a categorical
encoding is kind of a compression
uh measure and actually it makes things
faster
not slower but if we're dealing with
strings that's particularly true
you see on the right hand side uh dfu or
cole's pt value counts
the original data takes 1.96 seconds
nearly two seconds
when i do it on df slimmer calls for the
categorical data type
it's 146 milliseconds so it's over 10
times faster
that's because rather than counting
strings we're counting numbers and then
just representing the strings at the end
so how many sales do we actually see
over the course of uh
of the the years uh here if i just do a
group buy on year and pt that's property
type
we can see that prior to the great
recession so prior to 2007 property
sales are increasing then they all
decline
and then they begin to increase 2020 is
a partial year of course so don't worry
too much about that decline in sales
that you can see there
really look up to 2019 so we can see the
sales have recovered somewhat
what does that group buy cost us well
we're gonna have to look into that with
a memory profiler
so the memory profiler package is a
really interesting package
it lets us dig into the memory usage in
a python process
you can look at individual lines of
memory cost inside your module
you can track a whole program's
execution with improv small diagram on
the right we'll see a larger version
later
and you can track the usage of a single
command with percent
memit so if we use percent minute
on our group by df group by year where
we take the size of that grouping
we can see that it costs 388 megabytes
on the right hand side you can see that
the shape of that final result is 26
items
so it feels kind of expensive just to
summarize something down to
26 items um if i do a group buy on year
and pt
property type that costs nearly a
gigabyte 929 megabytes and if i do it on
three items year pt and new
it costs 1.1 gigabytes so that's really
quite a lot that's going on in the
background
even though that the unique result out
of that is 247 items
now you might wonder if using the
categorical version saves us ram and
makes this faster sadly it doesn't have
much of an effect on the
group by uh so it gives us more ram to
play with for representing the data but
it doesn't make the group by operation
go much faster but
actually we have to go to some other
tooling you can see here that the peak
memory is now up to
13 gigabytes i started with 10 gigabytes
uh just by adding in
a couple of group pies and receiving
some operations so my family's growing
quite a lot
i've actually opened the ticket on the
pandas website uh surprisingly large for
every usage and group by uh you might be
interested in having a look at that to
see if you can learn something as that
discussion moves forwards
now there's a a tool that i've written
which extends the memory profile
called the ipython memory usage it's
kind of an auto percent member
at the top you can see the result of
percent memo on a group by of three
items it tells us we incremented by 1.1
gigabytes
if we use ipython memory usage every
time you run a cell in your jupyter
notebook or your ipython shell it does
that mimic in the background
and so it reports how long the operation
took and what the
peak memory usage was whilst it ran and
what the current rat usage is
you may find that a useful tool if you
want your operations to go
faster then there's a couple of numeric
tools that you might introduce
one is bottleneck this gives us free
speed ups on math
in pandas and it doesn't get installed
by default you have to install it by
hand i'm always checking whenever i make
a new environment
do i have bottleneck oh no i don't i
better go and install it
if i use pd.options.com use bottleneck
force which turns off bottlenecks i've
got it installed and i'm disabling it
i take a float 64 column i've turned
price into a float64 so i've got a flip
64 floating point number
i take the mean 137 milliseconds if i
then turn
bottlenecks use back on and it's on by
default if you've got it installed
but here i've turned it off so i turn it
back on again now that same operation
costs 55 milliseconds
that's uh two to three times speed up
just by in
installing a free library that has no
downsides
so install bottleneck and also uh
install
numexpro that can make some of your
queries and eval operations go faster
if you know that you've got numeric data
and that you're using numpy in the
background it's a bit more of an
advanced tip here if you know that we're
using numpy's
representation so lowercase in 64.
lowercase flip 64.
you can use uh you can drop down to the
numpy representations and use the numpy
functions
if you know that you don't have nand
data in your column so no
not a numbers you can call two numpy
take the mean
16 milliseconds as opposed to taking the
original
price f64 column taking the mean in
pandas 55 milliseconds with bottleneck
that's because the pandas version is
checking for nands you're checking for a
lot of numbers which
might distort the results the numpy
version of mean there isn't doing that
check so it goes faster so it's a bit
more of an advanced tip
i've got uh more on that in my pi data
amsterdam 2020 talk which is on my blog
if you're interested
so here's a couple of tips use
categoricals
for speeding up uh your operations and
also to save ram doesn't work across the
board but generally they just work and
they just give you a free speed up but
certainly they free
uh free up a bunch of rams so you can
get more data into ram
if possible go from the default float 64
and into
64 columns down to in 32 and floats 32
your operations may perform faster
floats certainly tend to go a bit faster
with slow 32
but they'll use half the ram and that
will let you get more data
into ram before using other tools
install uh bottleneck and
numexpro they're just pip installs away
they give you free speed ups and pandas
but also be aware that we can only take
this so far to scale we really need to
go
for some newer tools
so what about desk so desk is a rich
library
like that desk is a rich library
wrapping
data frames and arrays and arbitrary
python functions so you can wrap up
uh pandas data frame like operations
numpy array-like operations or just
regular pythonic code with no scientific
work in the background at all
it's actually a very powerful and quite
complex tool
most people know that it's there for
speeding up pandas data frames
uh it actually wraps up pandas data
frames it doesn't re-implement them it
actually provides a wrapper around a
regular pants data frame
so you chunk up your data large data
frame into small chunks of data frames
and each of those become a das
distributed data frame
you can see in the diagram we've got a
set of collections we've got arrays
that's the numpy array for
larger than ram arrays the data frame
for power stage frames bags the latest
futures there's even a machine learning
component
behind the scenes we get a task graph of
decomposed tasks
and then these can be run on different
types of schedule there's a single
machine or a distributed scheduler
it's a very rich and complex ecosystem
it's not just about data frames that's
the one of the take times desk is not
just about data frames
when would you use it well if you've got
data that's bigger than ram
of course you need to use something like
this to be able to process your data
if you want to use all of your cores or
do you have cpu bound
functions operating on your data frames
or you're doing numpy array work which
is cpu bound then desk is a brilliant
idea
if your data fits into ram but you find
that some of your operations cause it to
run out of ram and you can't just
compress using the techniques we
used earlier then maybe das will give
you a solution as well
generally behind the scenes you'll be
using parquet data files
these are columnar data data files where
we store
snippets of our data so blocks of our
pandas data in
row blocks uh by columns where each
column can be compressed so we can load
in columns independently reducing the
amount of data that we load
uh das works with csv files and lots of
other numeric formats
but parquet is kind of where the sweet
spot is most of the time
there are dashboards inside dash that
give us rich diagnostics you can see one
of the task stream diagnostics on the
right hand side
and it lets you write pandas like code
the evaluation is lazy so you have to
add
dot compute onto the end of your chained
computations before anything gets
calculated
otherwise you're writing code you think
you've written pandas like code you get
no result and you're wondering what's
happened you put got computer on the end
and you get your results
so let's let's take a common uh pandas
operation so taking a time series and
re-sampling it
here i've already prepared my data i've
read in my csv firewood desk and i've
written out a hundred parquet partitions
you can do that in a
couple of lines in desk very easily so
i've written out my data i've compressed
it with the snappy compressor that's one
of the tools that's used by default in
parquet
and you can see on the right hand side
my uh a little snapshot of my parquet
folder actually these files are 20
megabytes each they're probably too
small typically with parquet we might
use 100 megabyte files the 20 megabyte
files means that
each time i load one of those chunks of
data into memory i don't use a lot of
ram
on the left hand side you can see that
i've specified two columns date and pt
the property type that i put into my
read parquet function this means read
parquet only reads in two columns
rather than the 15 or so columns that
exist so there's less data to bring up
from the disk
and bring it around you can see a little
representation of that in the bottom
left-hand corner
at the bottom right hand side you can
see my ddf
query so ddf is a distributed data frame
uh that's the
das distributed variant of a data frame
i give it a query that's just a regular
uh
pandas query give me uh all the items in
a certain date range
set the index the date that's like the
set index uh inside
pandas that's actually quite slow when
you're doing it on lots of partial files
these are 100 parquet files that are
written out
and then having set the index i would
like to do a resample to weekly from
daily data
and i want to count the results and then
i dot compute
and that gives me my weekly completions
the sum of number of houses are actually
sold per week
that costs nine seconds so you can see
it's pretty easy to put together it
looks
like regular pandas and i get access to
all of the underlying pandas
functionality
like daytime re-sampling which is
brilliant that's one of the powerful
areas
of pandas now what's happening in the
background
well we can use the memory profiler
again in a different way with the
improv tool this we use at the command
line you can see at the bottom of the
screen there improv run
track multi-process and include the
children
desk spawns out children child processes
if you only include the parent process
you'd only see a tiny snapshot of the
ram being used you wouldn't see the
workers in the background
here we can see the workers as well so
uh the
the green and the red line that are
bobbling at around 200 to 400 megabytes
that's the two
children processes that i've spawned off
reading in a parquet file doing a bit of
work
uh doing a group buy in this case and
then dropping that park if on and
reading in the next one and repeating
and repeating and repeating
until they've done all of their partial
pieces of work and they communicate the
result back
the black line at the top is the
aggregate ram usage for all of the
children processes
and we can see that in total this desk
operation is costing 1.2 gigabyte
way less than the 10 gigabyte that we
had with the pandas version earlier on
so this takes two processes 1.2
gigabytes
and in fairness here i'm actually
loading in all of the data rather than
just a couple of columns just to try to
amplify the memory usage the actual
memory usage if you optimize how you
write this code is much less in this
particular case
if i change this and go for 16 processes
then we can see now i'm up to six
gigabytes of total ram usage rather than
being 45 seconds to execute i'm down to
about 25 seconds
uh so it's still it's not super quick
but it's still pretty quick it's not as
quick as it could because i'm loading in
too much data and i could further
optimize this and simplify the process
um which is one of the nice things uh
with desk i've got a lot of control over
what i read in
what i process and what i do with it but
the take home here is at the beginning
we started with pandas with 10 gigabytes
plus before we did any operations
now doing the same operations on the
same data i'm maxing out at 6 gigabytes
and getting a pretty good speed out of
my operation
on the right hand side you can see the
task list
from the desk dashboard for this
particular operation
because here i've asked well in two
years how many completions do i get
resamples to a weekly basis you know hey
there'll be some time serious dynamics
behind this well it turns out over those
two years we can see an interesting
trend every year
sales start lower in the year and then
over the course of the year they get
higher then at christmas they drop back
and then they start climbing again and
so we see this kind of strange sort of
jesus pattern going on over the course
of each year
you could imagine having not 25 million
records but hundreds of millions of
records
and the same process would work with the
same brand footprint it would just take
longer to execute
so here's some desk tips you want to
keep it simple and i promise you you
really want to keep it simple when you
start out there's lots of moving parts
the documentation is very good a couple
of years ago the docs once ago now the
docs are
very good but you do want to keep it
simple it's easy to
start running before you can walk trip
up and then you hurt yourself and you
cry
because it's not obvious what's going on
because there are many moving parts in
desk
start with fewer processes you can
control this when you make up a local
cluster
fewer processes with lots of ram in
there and then reduce the ram
and increase the number of processes and
change your parquet partition sizes when
you get an idea as to how your
competition computation is performing
always remember to call dot compute if
possible
take your distributed data frame and
call sample and ask for say
one percent of the data this means only
one percent is flowing through the
entire process
so rather than waiting 30 seconds of
results you might wait just a couple of
seconds
you can interactively debug a heck of a
lot easier that way and remember that
desk is not just about data frames it
also wraps up distributed arrays for
numpy like operations
a bag which is a it's kind of a
combination of a set and a list in pure
python
delayed functions and lots more
so sqlite is an under used and i think
underrated tool
sqlite is a single file
sql database solution it's not specific
to python
it's been around for 20 years it's got
over 2 million tests
it's arguably the most widely deployed
database on the planet
because it's plumbed into android and
java and python and firefox and chrome
it's just baked into a whole bunch of
tools because it's really good
when you ask someone hey would you
consider using say sqlite rather than
postgres they may well say well no it's
a toy database you can't really do very
much with it well that's kind of true
you know you can only store 281
terabytes of data
into one of these databases it's not
designed for scaling it's not designed
for
heavy write volumes or multi-user write
access really it's designed for
read read heavy access patterns light
writing
and single user access or multi-user
without multi-user rights
so there are limitations around it but
it comes as a single 700 kilobyte
executable
and it has a very small ram footprint so
we can do things like
use sql alchemy to bind a connection to
a local on disk
sqlite database we can export from
pandas to this sql so i can
write out my pandas data frame into
sqlite and i get a four gigabyte file
and then i could run a query select
county and count star
from this table grouping by county i
wait two seconds because i put an index
onto
the county table and then i get my data
frame back when i do my read sql i get a
data frame i can do a set index because
it's a data frame
and it just works so if you're
collaborating with other users
who are more sql friendly or you want a
single file of data that you could
source control with a well understood
binary format
so now messing around with csv files
which are hard to interpret
and different tools interpret them
differently do consider using an sqlite
database
and it's under appreciated that
typically it's fast enough for many
applications and for multiple users to
use at a time
and it can read gigabytes and terabytes
worth of data
so what about vakes this is a newer data
frame
system so it's uh it's a lesser known
pandas alternative
it's designed to handle billions of rows
and probably they're stored in a single
hdf5
file on your hard drive so really it's
designed for local computation on one
large file and one large hard drive so
unlike das which can
scale to multiple machines and multiple
files
vegas is designed really to work on uh
on this single file on one machine
but hey that gets us way beyond the
limitations of pandas on our one machine
and we can rent very big machines
it uses memory mapping so it keeps ram
usage low
and keeps on paging its operations onto
the disk just like sqlite is doing in
the background using very sensible
technologies that are well understood
um it enables efficient group buyers
it's got faster string handling than we
have in pandas i've actually seen 10
times faster string operations
with vagues with its uh data stored on
disk that i have with pandas in ram
uh because they've uh rewritten the
string operations in c plus plus
uh it's numpy focus for its data type so
it doesn't have the pandas extension
times as the underlying numpy data types
that we used to
and it also has frameworks for machine
learning and for visualizing
large data sets which is a really a very
interesting addition i think
and it uses a lazy expression system
that's similar not the same as desks but
similar to desks
it does have fewer users and fewer aggro
smaller activity on github the core
developers are very focused but it's a
younger smaller project
um so go there remembering that it's not
pandas and it's not desk uh it's
something that's very similar
and with different performance
characteristics so typically we convert
our data from a csv file to hdf5 files
that's pretty easy there's a couple of
built-in functions to it took me five
minutes
once you've converted it opening the
file is instantly uses memory mapping so
there's nothing to read when you open it
and then you run queries and then run in
the background
multi-core it actually just works it's
it i found it actually a bit easier to
get started once i've got my head around
it
with vagues than with uh with desk for a
single large file on one machine
and the results that you get look like
pandas data frames the operations look
like pandas operations
but they're not so you can see at the
top here on the left hand side i've
opened a vdf i've called it a vdf just
to differentiate it from the ddf from
desk
and the df from pandas so the vdf is of
xdf here here in my example
i've opened a file to give it a file
name it opens up the hdf5 file that we
created before you can see that i pull
out the day of week from vdf.date we've
got the familiar dt
accessor and then i do a group by on day
of week and hear you pass in the
aggregation as an argument so it looks
like pandas but it's not quite the same
way the pandas does it
and then i sort the item that comes out
the other side if i ask for its type
i'm told that it's a data frame arrays
objects it's clearly not a pandas
a pandas data frame i can convert this
to a pandas data frame fakes allows that
um but here i've got the vagues uh the
base version of their data frames
on the right hand side we can see the
output of that so what does it mean to
have
completions counted by day of week it
turns out in the uk housing market
most of the time when you actually
complete and buy a house it's meant to
occur during the work working week any
time during the working week typically
it works out that it completes on the
friday everything gets pushed to the
friday
in the hope that you can move on a
saturday and you can see there's even a
couple of completions that happen on
saturdays and sundays for those unlucky
few
it's a strange distortion and dynamic in
the uk market
bottom right corner i've got a percent
time on the vdf group by on day of week
and it took under one and a half seconds
to do that operation
it's one and a half seconds and the
thing to remember is if i use improv
to look at the ram usage of the
operation and any of these operations
rather than loading in 10 gigabytes
worth of data or as we saw with desk
and several gigabytes through to say 20
30 gigabytes
here the operations typically append
under a gigabyte in rams as ram usage is
much lower
not as low as sqlite that tends to stick
at around 90 megabytes so hardly
anything at all
trading off less speed for lower ram
usage
here vagues trades off trades off
some speed and has more data in ram
and that's kind of like the the size of
the group by that i had in pandas
originally but just the pandas
group by operation not all of the data
stored into ram originally here all that
data doesn't end up stored around
because it's kept on disk
so a bunch of these operations you'd
normally do in pandas when they're in
ram actually occur at a similar speed
if not faster so string operations are
much faster with fakes than they are
currently
in pandas which i think is really
interesting
so where might you use these well desk
is multi-core and multi-machine and
multifile friendly
vagues tends to work with multi-core on
a single machine
typically with a single file desk allows
most of pandas and sports uh
huge numpy arrays and bags and others
both can handle billions of rows and
they can do machine learning and both
have readable codes if you have to go
and diagnose the code both have very
readable code so in summary well
you can make your data and pandas
smaller and you can make your operations
faster but at some point you run out of
ram still
then maybe if you want the core pandas
functionality and that's what you're
most used to
maybe you want to stick with desk
because that gives you access to all of
the pandas underlying features
if you're working with numpy data types
and not the pandas extension types and
you're working less with time series
operations
then i think vagues might be a very
interesting alternative
um because it enables you to write
arbitrary python code which is run
across these very large data frames up
to billions of rows very happily
uh i've got loads of public material
from a sequence of talks that i've been
giving over the last year
uh and actually over the last bunch of
years up on my blog you're very welcome
to go and look at those
and i've got a course based around this
this high performance computing details
will be on my blog if you're in the game
i've written a book on this as i
mentioned at the beginning that's my
high performance book
uh it's it's got over 400 pages of this
stuff so if you want to learn more about
this high performance area grab a copy
of that book i'd love to sign it if i
see you at a conference in the future
and if you look over my shoulder you can
see postcards up on the wall
uh when i give conference talks now i
ask hey if i've taught you something
please
send me a postcard i love collecting
postcards from around the world so if
you'd like to send me a postcard send me
an email i would love to receive one
i'd love to know what it was that you
found most useful so i remember to say
thank you to your organizers and the
other presenters around at the
conference
uh and uh well i look forward to meeting
you online during the q a thanks for
watching